bueno hay un ambiente un poco de
frustración y decepción la campaña en
esta segunda ronda se ha centrado más en
los aspectos negativos y las críticas
hacia las y los dos candidatos y eso al
final ha dejado básicamente un empate
técnico según lo que proyectaron las
últimas encuestas además hay un 18% de
la ciudadanía que dijo que se encontraba
todavía indistinta en la última semana y
que si no tendría algún impacto en en
los presentados que podríamos ver el día
de hoy a lo mejor a eso de las 8 de la
noche ya tendríamos el 14 por ciento de
los votos escrutados también un factor
importante sería el del abstencionismo
en la primera ronda se registró el mayor
abstencionismo con más del 40 por ciento
de personas que no asistieron a votar y
el factor más importante dentro de toda
la campaña activo el tema económico
costa rica al igual que el resto de
países de latinoamérica sufrido por la
pandemia en 2020 su producto interno
bruto se contrajo en el 4.1 por ciento
esto fue la contracción más grande en
las últimas cuatro décadas por lo cual
es el tema central de la campaña